Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速通知大家一个正在发生的激动人心的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间去换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊主讲的“通往定期收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志于成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. with Dr. Marianne Trent.
这些原则对你同样适用。挑战赛还设有由丽莎亲自颁发的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士一对一咨询一小时的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。请访问我的 Linktree 页面 Dr. Marianne Trent，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我就会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。如果你正期待成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目指引你吧。与玛丽安·特伦特博士同行。
Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. So if you're listening to this in the first week of its release then you might well be aware that in the UK, the clearing house applications have not long closed. They closed on the 16th of November. So you might be listening to this trying to think about, you know, my application's gone in. Now I've got to wait till spring. Or you might, you know, might not have chosen to apply this year or not been eligible to apply this year or not maybe even thinking about going down the clinical psychology route but you could be experiencing a number of different thoughts and feelings whilst you're listening to this episode so I just wanted to to get on board with whatever you are feeling and
嗨，欢迎来到《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。如果你是在本期节目发布的头一周收听，你可能很清楚，在英国，清算所（Clearing House）的申请通道不久前刚刚关闭。它们在 11 月 16 日关闭了。所以你听这期节目的时候，可能在想：你知道的，我的申请已经交上去了，现在我只能等到春天了。或者你可能没有选择在今年申请，或者今年没有资格申请，甚至可能根本没考虑走临床心理学这条路。但你在听这期节目时，可能会产生各种各样的想法和感受，所以我只想与你共情你所感受到的
thinking and if you want to talk about it do come and join us in the Aspiring Psychologist Community Group and let's talk about it in there. So today I thought we'd think about finding your tribe and why that can be so important. So come to a psychology career you'd usually need to be at least beyond the age of 21, you're usually post post degree so you might already have had experiences good or bad in your secondary education your sixth form education and your undergraduate and maybe even your postgraduate education that have felt either good or bad in terms of feeling well connected well supported and well understood by those around you. You might feel like you're in a really good position where you already have your tribe lined up. I certainly spent the weekend with three of my tribe, people that I met at undergraduate
和思考的一切。如果你想聊聊，快来加入我们的“有志心理学家社区群”（Aspiring Psychologist Community Group），我们在那儿聊聊吧。所以今天我想我们来聊聊寻找你的“同频圈”（tribe），以及为什么它如此重要。要开启心理学职业生涯，你通常需要年满 21 岁以上，通常已经毕业了。所以你在中学教育、预科教育、本科教育甚至研究生教育中，可能已经有过或好或坏的经历——在感受到与周围人联系紧密、获得良好支持和充分理解方面，这些经历有好有坏。你可能会觉得自己处于一个非常有利的位置，已经有了志同道合的圈子。我这个周末确实和我的三个圈中人度过了，她们是我在本科
university. So I had course friends, psychology friends, and I had the housemates that I met at undergraduate university. So I had course friends, psychology friends, and I had the housemates that I lived with. And so I was with my housemates this weekend. And it was lots of fun. And I definitely, as I said, consider them my tribe, but they're not necessarily my psychology tribe, because none of them were studying psychology and none of them work in that sphere. But I know I've spoken before in one of the early episodes about my experiences of working in a local government agency. Makes it sound slightly more exciting than it was. Makes it sound like I'm kind of some sort of, yeah, Will Smith character. But that's not the case. I was working for local government and yeah I just felt like I didn't really have my tribe around me at that stage so all of my psychology friends were living in
大学认识的朋友。所以我有课程上的朋友、心理学朋友，还有我在本科大学合租的室友。所以我这个周末和我的室友们在一起，真的非常开心。正如我所说，我绝对认为她们是我的圈子，但她们不一定是我的心理学圈子，因为她们中没有人学心理学，也没有人在那个领域工作。不过我知道我之前在早期的一期节目中谈到过我在地方政府机构工作的经历。这听起来比实际情况稍微刺激了一点，听起来我好像是什么威尔·史密斯式的角色，但事实并非如此。我当时是在为地方政府工作，是的，我只是觉得在那个人生阶段，周围并没有真正属于我的圈子。我所有的心理学朋友都住在
different areas of the country I wasn't yet working in a psychology service and I just was feeling quite lonely and quite isolated. If I was offering advice to myself now for then, I think that's what this episode is going to be. And it might be useful for you right now, it might be useful for you in the future, or it might be useful for people that you meet along the way. So I'm going to be taking you through a few different steps and stages that might be useful for you or someone you know for making the most of where you're at right now to just optimally feel supported, understood, validated, seen, heard. And like, yeah, like people know you, see you and are on your page. That's what I think about as your tribe being. So with no further ado, let's crack on.
国家的不同地区，我当时还不在心理学服务机构工作，我只是觉得相当孤独和孤立。如果让我把现在的建议送给当时的自己，我想这就是这期节目要讲的内容。它可能对现在的你有用，可能对未来的你有用，也可能对你在路上遇到的人有用。所以我将带领大家经历几个不同的步骤和阶段，这可能对你或你认识的人有所帮助，让你充分利用当下的处境，获得最佳的支持、理解、认可、关注和倾听。并且感觉，是的，就像有人了解你、看得见你并且与你同频。这就是我所理解的你的“圈子”。废话不多说，我们开始吧。
So I think the first stage is to think about, well, who are they? You know, you might want to think about making a list about if you were being optimally supported seen understood validated who and what would be doing that for you would it be stuff professionally would it be stuff personally you know or would it be you know mixture of those things might even be something spiritual or religious or faith-based for you. But if you had to kind of get a nice big bit of paper and just, you know, just encourage yourself to free-form doodle, if you like, or note-take, if that's more up your street, who and what areas of your life might that include um that you'd want to cultivate so for me at the time um I guess you know I had a partner at the time and we had an active social life in that regard but I was probably a bit lonely you know I think one of my friends who I've previously seen quite a lot of had a young child and so we did that but we didn't necessarily do the socializing in the same way so I think I was a bit lonely and feeling a bit career isolated so
所以我觉得第一阶段是思考：嗯，他们是谁？你知道，你可能会想列一个清单：如果你得到了最佳的支持、被看到、被理解、被认可，谁以及什么事情会为你做到这一点？这会是职业方面的事情吗？会是个人方面的事情吗？你知道的，还是说这会是这些事情的混合体？甚至可能是对你来说某种精神上的、宗教的或信仰相关的东西。但是，如果你必须拿出一张很大很好的纸，然后，你知道的，鼓励自己进行自由涂鸦，或者做笔记（如果这更合你心意的话），这可能会包括你想要培养的你生活中的哪些人和哪些领域？嗯，对我来说，在那个时候，嗯，我猜（你知道的）我当时有一个伴侣，我们在那方面有活跃的社交生活，但我可能有点孤独。你知道，我认为我之前经常见的一个朋友有一个小孩，所以我们一起做过那些事，但我们不一定以同样的方式进行社交。所以我想我当时有点孤独，并感到职业上的孤立，所以
you know this was in the late 2000s and things have moved on somewhat since then so I'm gonna I'm gonna advise myself and forward slash you about what things you can do right now that might be useful so one of them obviously is thinking about whether you can do right now that might be useful. So one of them obviously is thinking about whether you can join groups. And that might be groups in person, it might be groups, you know, remotely, it might be joining Facebook groups, it might be joining, I don't know, different communities online that don't involve Facebook. It might involve, you know, joining clubs as well. So at this stage of my life, I decided that I would drag a friend along and we'd learn to do Chinese cookery. So we went to an evening class and learned that. So there might
你知道，这是在 2000 年代末，从那以后事情已经有了一些进展，所以我要向自己以及斜杠听众们建议，你现在可以做哪些可能有用的事情。所以其中一件显然是考虑你现在是否能做点什么，这可能会有帮助。所以其中一件显然是考虑你是否可以加入各种小组。这可能是面对面的小组，也可能是远程的小组，可能是加入脸书小组，可能是加入我不知道的、不涉及脸书的不同在线社区。这也可能涉及加入各种俱乐部。所以在我人生的这个阶段，我决定拉着一个朋友去学做中国菜。于是我们去上了夜校并学会了。所以可能
be some other skills and some other ways that you can connect and have fun and enjoy things that might not look like you might imagine they would look. I was looking on my local recovery and well-being academy, for example, recently. And on that, there's loads and loads of free courses that you can go to or that you can refer your clients to as well, that sound really exciting, you know, really nice opportunities to learn things, and to do things that you might not have experienced before. And similarly, in the adult education provision near you. So if you were to Google adult education, whichever is your nearest city or town, there might well be stuff that you can look through there. And yeah, you could learn another language, you know you could learn another language you could do some cookery you could do some baking you could do some craft um
会有其他一些技能，以及其他一些连接、获得乐趣和享受事物的方式，它们可能看起来不像你想象的那样。例如，我最近在看我当地的康复与福祉学院（recovery and well-being academy）。上面有大量免费课程，你可以去上，也可以推荐给你的客户，听起来真的很令人兴奋，你知道的，这是学习新事物、做一些你以前可能没经历过的事情的绝佳机会。同样，在你附近的成人教育机构也是如此。所以如果你去谷歌搜索成人教育，搜索离你最近的城市或镇，那里很可能会有你可以浏览的内容。是的，你可以学习另一门语言，你知道你可以学习另一门语言，你可以做一些烹饪，你可以做一些烘焙，你可以做一些手工艺，嗯
some of my clients enjoy i don't know metal work and glass fusion and all sorts of stuff like glass blowing um there's many many opportunities for you to do new things and they don't always need to be massively costly things as well so could you look at what um what activities or clubs or groups you could join and of course it might well include looking out for any local research groups or any local assistant psychologist or aspiring psychologist groups and i'd be remiss if I wasn't to say that people have made nice connections through the aspiring psychologist membership as well. So that might be a group that you might like to consider joining. Details are in the show notes. What you might find during
我的一些客户喜欢，我不知道，金属加工和玻璃熔接，还有各种各样的东西，比如吹玻璃。这里有非常多的机会让你去尝试新事物，而且它们通常不需要花费巨资。所以你可以看看你可以加入什么活动、俱乐部或小组，当然，它很可能会包括寻找任何当地的研究小组，或者任何当地的助理心理学家或有志心理学家小组。如果我不说人们通过“有志心理学家会员计划”（aspiring psychologist membership）也建立了美好的联系，那就是我的失职了。所以那可能是一个你可能会考虑加入的小组。详情在节目简介中。你可能会发现
all of this process is that throughout this, you find yourself as well. and maybe you realize it was yourself you were looking for all along but you might exacerbate that by perhaps joining part of a therapy group or I think when I was an aspiring psychologist sometimes there were like dynamic group therapies that you could join and if you were a student, there was lower cost options available as well. So it might be worth Googling whether that might be a possibility for you. Or of course, you might be able to enter into a one-to-one therapy relationship, which might well help you now, but might well help you professionally as well. So that's something else to explore. So let's take this opportunity to have a little break and I'll be back along very shortly
在整个过程中，你会在此期间发现真正的自己。也许你会意识到，你一直在寻找的其实正是你自己。但你可能会通过参加某个治疗小组的一部分来加剧这种发现，或者我想当我是一名有志心理学家时，有时会有你可以加入的动态团体治疗，如果你是学生，还有更低成本的选择。所以谷歌一下这是否对你来说是一种可能性是值得的。或者当然，你也可以建立一对一的治疗关系，这不仅现在能帮到你，对你的职业生涯也大有裨益。所以这也是另一个值得探索的方向。那么，让我们借此机会休息一下，我很快就会回来
so many tips and lessons to learn from so many things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. welcome back along thank you for sticking with me i hope you're finding the content useful can't quite believe we're at episode 50 um i don't know where the time is going but it's been a lovely journey and thank you for all of the kind words about our recent episodes and like i said in episode 49 if you are an aspiring psychologist and you've got a useful or interesting story or take on the world then do please get in contact with me and we will see whether we can get a podcast episode happening with you at the centre of it to provoke and encourage important and useful conversations for people. Okay, so in the first half, we've covered three
有这么多的技巧和经验可以学习，有这么多的事情可以尝试。“有志心理学家集体”（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）。“有志心理学家集体”。欢迎回来，谢谢你一直陪伴着我，希望你觉得这些内容很有用。真不敢相信我们已经做到第 50 期节目了，我不知道时间都去哪儿了，但这真是一段美好的旅程，感谢大家对我们最近几期节目的赞美之词。正如我在第 49 期节目中所说，如果你是一位有志心理学家，并且你有一个有用或有趣的故事或对世界的看法，请务必与我联系，我们将看看是否能以你为核心制作一期播客节目，为人们引发和鼓励重要且有用的对话。好了，所以在前半部分，我们涵盖了三
forward slash four different points for thinking about finding your tribe. And in this section, we have three more. So we're going to go through three more ways that you might be able to find your tribe or things to consider when finding your tribe along the way. So the next one is saying yes. If you can, you know, when you're offered opportunities at work, if it feels a little bit scary, but just about within your comfort zone, then could you say yes? You know, could you explore what that might, you know, look like for you? Or when you're offered chances to do things socially, you know, could you say yes to that? Or if someone does phone you up out of the blue and say, do you fancy a Chinese cookery course? Could you say yes to that? So obviously, make sure you're staying safe safe make sure you're looking after yourself making wise choices but what could you say yes to and when you're offered things and you immediately
斜杠四个关于思考如何寻找你的“圈子”的要点。在本节中，我们还有另外三个要点。所以我们要介绍另外三种寻找你的“圈子”的方法，或者一路上寻找你的“圈子”时需要考虑的事情。接下来的一点是：学会说“好”。如果可以的话，你知道的，当你在工作中被提供机会时，如果它感觉有点吓人，但刚好在你的舒适区之内，那你能不能答应呢？你知道的，你能探索这可能对你意味着什么吗？或者当你被提供社交的机会时，你知道的，你能答应吗？或者如果有人真的突然给你打电话说：“你想去上中国菜烹饪课吗？”你能答应吗？所以显然，要确保你保持安全，确保你照顾好自己，做出明智的选择。但你能对什么事情说“好”呢？当别人给你提供机会时，你立刻
think no what might that be about you know of course you get to choose and you get to say no and if you really don't want to do things you don't have to do them but if we notice that we're having an immediate oh no I can't or I shouldn't or I mustn't it might be worth just exploring and gently pressing the edges of what that might be about so just to be a little bit more playful a little bit more curious as you consider what you could say yes to or what you could say I'm gonna just give that a go and see what I think to rather than you know out and out saying no to something so that's just another little option another little idea and the next of our suggestions is reflection so could you use your reflective journal or just your general musings whilst
心里想“不”，这可能意味着什么呢？你知道的，当然你有权做出选择，也有权说“不”。如果你真的不想做某事，你大可不必去做。但如果我们注意到自己有一种即时的“哦不，我不能”或者“我不应该”或者“我绝不能”的想法，或许值得去探索并轻轻触碰这种想法边缘的含义。也就是在你考虑对什么事情说“好”，或者对什么事情说“我来试试看我的感觉如何”时，表现得更有趣一点、更好奇一点，而不是一刀切地对某事说“不”。所以这只是另一个小选项、另一个小主意。而我们的下一个建议是：反思。所以，你可以利用你的反思日记，或者只是在
you're stuck at traffic lights or driving along the motorway to think about all of this process really to think about your experiences you might well find it helpful to listen to the episode where I talk about important people I have met along the way and if you wanted to have a listen to that that's episode 33 of the aspiring psychologist podcast but reflection really is the thing that's going to make the difference for you in terms of I don't know being at peace with yourself I think so I feel like I am constantly reflecting but in a way that feels really comforting. It doesn't feel critical. It feels helpful and exploratory. And like I'm on my own team, it doesn't feel like I'm trying to knock myself down, you know, quite the opposite. If I have an idea, I think, oh, you know, how could you make
堵在红绿灯前或开在高速公路上时的胡思乱想，来真正思考整个过程，思考你的你自己的经历。你可能会发现，听我讲述一路上遇到的重要人物的那期节目会对你有所帮助。如果你想听那一期，那是《有志心理学家播客》的第 33 期。但反思确实是能为你带来改变的事情，就比如，我不知道，与自己和平相处，我是这么觉得的。我觉得我一直在反思，但这种方式感觉非常安慰。它不是批判性的。它是有帮助的、探索性的。而且就像我是我自己的队友一样，感觉不像是我想把自己打倒，你知道的，恰恰相反。如果我有一个想法，我会想：哦，你知道的，你怎样才能让它实现呢？或者是什么在阻碍着你？是什么阻止了你去做那件事？而且，你知道的，把这作为你的内心独白，而不是让它听起来更刻薄，会让你有什么收获呢？
that happen? Or what's holding you back? What's stopping you from doing that? And, you know, how might you benefit from having that as your inner monologue rather than something that might feel a bit more mean? So yeah, if you would find it helpful, please do have another listen to the episode on compassion as well. And is episode four knew it was I had to check um okay yeah getting to be uh quite the expert with these episode numbers but don't like to falsely signpost you so yeah it's just reflection reflection reflection in a way that feels not overwhelming in a way that feels like you're not being overly neurotic um it's just I don't know like a nice companion almost like I can have a chat with myself I can have a chat with someone that has the same values as me and wants the same
所以，是的，如果你觉得有帮助，请务必再听听关于同理心的那一期节目。那是第 4期，我知道，我得核实一下……好的，是的，对于这些期数我已经变得相当专业了，但我不喜欢给你错误的指引。所以，是的，这就是反思、反思、再反思，以一种不会让人不知所措的方式，以一种让你觉得你没有过度神经质的方式。它只是，我不知道，就像一个很好的伴侣，几乎就像我可以和自己聊天，我可以和有和我相同价值观、想要相同
things I guess it's about becoming your own best friend um and I never feel lonely you know when you're your own best friend but it's also about um you know challenging yourself to get out there and make new friends and to you know have those opportunities so you know absolutely if you're more of an introvert and you like to keep yourself to yourself, that's OK. But when we do say no more often, there might be less opportunities for us to find the joy or to find new experiences and find our tribe along the way. And certainly, you know, when I was working as an assistant psychologist, many of the people who I was working with as fellow assistants now form part of my sort of daily tribe even now I'm qualified and again people that I that I did my training with that were part of my tribe then continue to be part of my tribe now and even two of those in the last couple of days I've spoken to as well so these might not necessarily be relationships just for now that
东西的人聊天。我想这关乎于成为你自己的最好朋友。当你成为自己的最好朋友时，你永远不会感到孤独。但这也关乎于，你知道的，挑战自己走出去结交新朋友，并拥有这些机会。所以，绝对地，如果你更内向，喜欢独处，那也没关系。但当我们更频繁地拒绝时，我们找到快乐、获得新体验以及在途中找到我们的“圈子”的机会可能会减少。当然，你知道的，当我担任助理心理学家时，和我一起工作的许多同行助理，即使在我获得资格之后，现在也构成了我日常“圈子”的一部分。同样，和我一起接受培训、当时属于我的“圈子”的人，现在继续成为我“圈子”的一部分，就在过去几天里我还和其中两个人沟通过。所以这些不一定只是眼下的关系
you're cultivating. These might be longer term, maybe forever relationships as well. So when we're looking at different qualities of relationships, I don't know if you've heard this, but we can think about friends for a reason, friends for a season and friends for a lifetime and sometimes we'll have disappointments when we realize that what we thought was friends for a lifetime became friends for a season. Okay so friends for a reason we often think about as being for a specific kind of purpose that you've expressed so for example example, if you're going through grief, or if you had, you know, someone who's unwell, then you might seek out people who have similar experiences. And so there's a reason that brought you together. A season might be, you know, whilst
你在培养的关系。这些也可能是更长期的、也许是永远的关系。所以当我们看待不同品质的关系时，我不知道你是否听说过这个：我们可以把朋友分为“因缘之交”（friends for a reason）、“阶段之交”（friends for a season）和“一生之交”（friends for a lifetime）。有时当我们意识到我们以为是一生之交的朋友变成了阶段之交的朋友时，我们会感到失望。好吧，所以因缘之交，我们通常认为是为了你所表达的一种特定目的。例如，如果你正在经历悲伤，或者你有一个生病的人，那么你可能会寻找有相似经历的人。所以是某种原因把你们聚集在一起。一个阶段可能是，你知道的，当
you have kids in the same primary school, or whilst you're working in a certain workplace or, you know, whilst you're living next door or nearby to somebody. And friends for a lifetime could be any of those who then become longer term friends. So your friends for a lifetime might be someone that you went to primary school with, it might be someone that you went to secondary or uni with, and they suddenly, you know, they go past the point where it was for a reason they go past the point where it's for a season because that thing changes and then they progress into friends for a lifetime so for example if I reflect on some of my assistant psychologist friendships then initially it was um friends for a reason shared a car to the same university to look around um an open day um and then it became friends for a season because we
你的孩子在同一所小学读书时，或者当你在某个工作场所工作时，或者当你们住在某人隔壁或附近时。而一生之交则可能是上述任何一种后来变成更长期朋友的人。所以你的一生之交可能是和你一起上小学的某个人，可能是和你一起上中学或大学的某个人，然后突然间，你知道的，他们超越了那种仅仅是因为某个原因的点，超越了仅仅是因为某个阶段的点，因为那个情况改变了，然后他们演变成了一生之交。所以，例如，如果我反思我的一些助理心理学家友谊，最初它是……因缘之交，拼车去同一所大学参观开放日；然后它变成了阶段之交，因为我们
used to meet for lunch while we were working there and now it's friends for a lifetime because we're choosing to make time for each other even though when we first met it was you know fast approaching 15 16 17 years ago something like that so you know we weather the storm and we choose to make time for each other um and that's how your tribe becomes formed so when it goes perhaps from reason to season to lifetime and And, you know, but you can still have a tribe who don't choose to keep in the long term, who just use really mindful ways of connecting to this season or this reason. But yeah, it's useful to have at any time, I think, a group of people in your life that are reason, a group of people in your life that are season, and a group of people that are
过去常常在那里工作时一起吃午饭；而现在它是一生之交，因为我们选择为彼此腾出时间，尽管我们第一次见面时，你知道的，已经是将近 15、16、17 年前的事了，诸如此类。所以，你知道的，我们经受住了风雨，我们选择为彼此留出时间，这就是你的“圈子”形成的方式。所以当它可能从原因过渡到阶段再到一生时，你知道的，但你仍然可以拥有一个并不打算长期交往的“圈子”，他们只是使用非常用心的联系方式来应对这个阶段或这个原因。但是，是的，我认为在任何时候，你的生活中都最好有一群因缘之交的朋友、一群阶段之交的朋友，以及一群
lifetime, because you get a different energy around all of that. So what do you think? What do you think to this? I would love to know. And of course, the final point is that we can recalibrate at any point. So if we do feel like we are missing some of these people in certain areas of our lives, we can recalibrate and reach out and change it. So yeah, I do hope you found that useful, my whistle stop tour through tribe making. And yeah, I would love your thoughts, as I say. And yeah, please do check out what other people also say in the Aspiring Psychologist Collective and the Clinical Psychologist Collective. I've got lots of great guest episodes coming up for the Aspiring Psychologist podcast soon. If you've got any in
一生之交的朋友，因为你可以从所有这些关系中获得不同的能量。你怎么看？你对这个有什么看法？我很想知道。当然，最后一点是，我们可以在任何时候重新校准（recalibrate）。所以如果我们确实觉得自己生活中的某些领域缺少了这些人，我们可以重新校准、伸出援手并做出改变。所以，是的，我真心希望你觉得我这次对“圈子”打造的旋风式游览是有用的。而且，正如我所说，我非常希望听到你的想法。是的，请务必查看其他人对“有志心理学家集体”和“临床心理学家集体”的评价。我的《有志心理学家播客》即将推出许多精彩的嘉宾访谈节目。如果你有任何
mind that you would find useful, then please do get in contact with me via the podcast page on my website, which you can find details in the show notes, or it is www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast and then you can also find out how to leave audio testimonials just with a few clicks of your mouse by that same page that same site so thank you so much for listening please do rate and review the podcast it's always so appreciated and I'll look forward to catching up with you for our next episode which is available to you from 6am on Monday. Don't set your alarm, it'll be there when you're ready. Take care. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast.
觉得有用的想法，请务必通过我网站上的播客页面与我联系，你可以在节目简介中找到详细信息，或者网址是 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast。然后你也可以通过同一个页面、同一个网站，只需点击几下鼠标，就能了解如何留下语音评价。非常感谢大家的收听，请务必给播客打分和评论，我们总是非常感激。我期待着在我们的下一期节目中与大家见面，该节目将于周一早上 6 点起向您提供。不用定闹钟，当你准备好时它就在那里。保重。有这个播客在身边，你就在通往合格的道路上。这就是《有志心理学家播客》。
With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持。我叫亚娜（Jana），我是一名见习心理健康从业人员。我读了《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现所有这些不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。达到这个目标有这么多不同的途径，这让我感到惊讶，而且没有完美的途径可以成为其中一员，这让我充满了信心：不，我没有做错，并减轻了我自己的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书来让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这期节目还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可留下评论。